Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir haben schon viel zu lange nicht mehr über die Premier League gesprochen. Da gibt es so viele Themen, das holen wir jetzt nach hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass mit Uli Hebel. Ich begrüße euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, und ich begrüße Uli Hebel von Click und Rush und natürlich von Sky und der Saunen. Hallo Uli.
Ich schließe mich an, hallo Höhrende, hallo Max.
Schön, dass du hier bist. Weißt du, wie viel die Ausgabe des Kurzpasses ist?
Es muss jetzt eine Runde sein. Oder du hast es extra für mich zur Nummer 23 werden lassen.
Nein, nein, es ist die Nummer 200, die wir gerade zusammen aufnehmen. Und da habe ich mir doch was ganz Besonderes ausgedacht, nämlich dass wir jetzt mal das nachholen, was in den letzten Wochen aus organisatorischen Gründen und Krankheitsgründen und alle möglichen Gründe kamen da zusammen nicht geklappt hat. Nämlich, dass wir mal über die Premier League sprechen. Da haben wir einen Füllhorn an Themen. Deswegen will ich gar nicht jetzt noch vorlabern, sondern fange direkt an. Uli, lass uns mal zuerst beginnen mit dem Verkauf von Chelsea. Roman Abramovic hat sich antizipierend dessen, was angesichts des Kriegs von Russland gegen die Ukraine passieren würde, von Chelsea getrennt. Es läuft jetzt schon die Biete runter an neue Käufer. Es gab harte Sanktionen, die auch Chelsea betroffen hätten. Die wurden jetzt schon ein bisschen gelockert. Also es sieht jetzt nach dem, was ich gelesen habe, nicht mehr so aus, als müsste man im Sechs-Sitzer zum nächsten Champions-League-Spiel in Madrid reisen. Wie ist denn der aktuelle Stand bei Chelsea?
Ja, also das werden wirklich interessante Wochen. 10. April geht es los mit dem Spiel City gegen Liverpool in Manchester. Das Ganze ist ins Sandwich eingepackt aus den Champions League Spielen. Da spielt Liverpool gegen Benfica und Manchester City tritt gegen Atletico Madrid an. Also Stichworten, Mannschaften, die sich gut einmauern. Könnten wir vielleicht auch nochmal ein Fallbeispiel sehen. Und dann treffen diese beiden Teams aber noch einmal aufeinander, nämlich im FA Cup-Halbfinale auch wieder in Manchester. Also diesen direkten Vergleich, wir werden ihn gleich zweimal bekommen. Einmal wird er –könnte er –die Meisterschaft entscheiden. Einmal wird er zumindest darüber schon mal entscheiden, wer ins Finale des FA Cup einzieht. Und zwischendurch müssen die beiden aber auch noch in der Champions League antreten. Also dieser berühmte heiße April, den wir bei den Top-Mannschaften dann eben immer sehen, er wird auch bei City und bei Liverpool auf jeden Fall zu beobachten sein. Im Grunde, wir müssen so langsam dann die Kurve kriegen, aber ich muss noch über ein emotionales Thema mit dir sprechen, Uli. Und zwar allein für mich emotional. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich den größten Glauben an den Fußball habe, aber es gab noch mal einen Stich in meinem Herz, und das war die Entlassung von Bielsa bei Leeds United. Jetzt springen wir thematisch ein bisschen. Ich fand das –ja, es gibt ja immer Gründe für eine Trainerentlassung, und auch bei Leeds lief es nicht gut. Aber kannst du es nachvollziehen, dass ich das eben aus diesen emotionalen Gründen mit der Geschichte von Leeds United, mit dem, was Marcelo Bielsa für diesen Verein getan hat, indem er sie endlich wieder in die Premier League geführt hat, dass ich damit meine Probleme mit dieser Entlassung hatte?
Die hatte ich auch, und ich glaube alle anderen auch. Weil man hatte das Gefühl, wenn irgendetwas reine Ergebnisse überdauern kann, dann ist es eine Geschichte wie diese von Bielsa und Leeds. Ich hatte genau dieselben Gedankengänge wie du. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man sich dann mal los sagt von den Gefühlen und sich die Fakten angeguckt hatte, dann kam man schon irgendwie auch zu den Ergebnissen. Einerseits ist das das, was ich an Marcelo Bielsa so sehr geschätzt habe, fast verehrt habe, dass er einfach gesagt hat, ne, auf meine Art, es gibt ja den berühmten Satz, wer den Plan B nimmt, der hat einfach nur nicht genügend Vertrauen in Plan A. Und das ist irgendwie auf eine Weise dumm. Auf eine andere Weise ist es so überzeugend und auch so überzeugend für mich gewesen, dass ich immer gehofft habe, dass Plan A wirklich funktioniert. Aber es gab diese Gegentorflut, die sie bekommen haben, sie sahen wirklich teilweise richtig, richtig schlecht aus. Und da konnte ich es dann schon verstehen, dass sie haben reagieren müssen. Also wenn man sich von allen Emotionen los sagt, dann glaube ich, ist das nachvollziehbar. Aber mir ging es wie dir auch. Das war eine ganz, ganz, ganz besondere Zeit, die es gab. Die war am Ende ja gar nicht so lang. Aber mit diesem Aufstieg, mit der Art und Weise, wie Bielsa das gemacht hat, mit seiner komischen, kautzigen Art und auf der anderen Seite, das hat trotzdem noch einnehmend gewesen. Und das hat so einen Typen wie ihn. Und diese Art und Weise, wie er diesen Verein geführt hat, die gab es ja in unserem Fußballkosmos so gar nicht mehr. Und deswegen hätte man sich, glaube ich, ich habe gar keine andere Stimme gelesen, gar nicht. Und das ist ja sehr, sehr selten. Ich glaube, jeder hätte sich gewünscht, dass es einfach weitergeht.
Bordeaux, Gräute-Fürth, Salah, Nitana und dann schon Leeds United. Das sind die schlechtesten Abwehrreihen, stand heute in Europa. Das ordnet das ein bisschen ein, was du angesprochen hast. Und jetzt hat ja Leeds als Nachfolger von Bielsa jemand bekommen, den wir auch jüngst beobachten konnten in der Bundesliga, nämlich Jesse Marsh wurde der neue Trainer. Allein der Ergebnisse nach hat sich ein bisschen etwas verändert. Man hat jetzt die letzten beiden Partien gewinnen können. Man musste auch dringend Punkte sammeln. Damit hat man jetzt eben sieben Punkte Vorsprung auf die Abstiegsplätze schon mal anhäufen können. Was hat Marsh verändert? Und glaubst du, dass wir aufgrund seines Engagements bei Leeds United mal anders auf ihn blicken werden, als jetzt über diese kurze Episode bei Leipzig, die wir alle mitbekommen haben?
Ja, die glaube ich viel überlagert hat, auch für mich auch. Also ich habe irgendwie eine Art von Sturheit kennengelernt, die ich nicht dachte, bei jemandem so zu sehen. Ich habe mir das auch durch eine Sonne nochmal bestätigen lassen. Das scheint bei Leeds anders zu sein. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe nichts in 90 Minuten gesehen von ihm bislang. Ich bin einfach zeitlich noch nicht dazugekommen. Ich habe es mir immer mal ausschnitteweise angeguckt und habe mir von einem Kollegen immer sagen lassen, wie es lief. Das heißt, alles was ich dir erzähle, ist nur zum Teil richtig oder hat keinen Anspruch auf Vollständigkeit. Es scheint so, als habe er an systematischen Abläufen in der Defensive etwas gearbeitet, arbeiten lassen, also sprich Restverteidigung und dergleichen. Das war ja das große Problem, dass Bielsa so cool ich das fand und so gerne ich es gesehen habe, aber er ließ ja am Ende 1 gegen 1 verteidigen und hat fast Mandeckung gespielt. Das geht eigentlich gar nicht. Und da hat Marsch wohl versucht, so habe ich es mir auch in ein paar Sequenzen in der Scouting-Plattform angeguckt, da hat er wohl versucht, mehr Hilfe herzustellen, also sprich eher im Kollektiv sich zusammenziehen zu lassen. Aber im gesamten dynamischen Prozess, ich müsste dir jetzt Käse erzählen, will ich nicht tun, ich habe sie mir noch nicht anschauen können.
Du kannst ja auch nicht alles sehen, nicht einmal du, lieber Uli. Dann ein aller, aller letztes Thema und dann ist leider diese wunderschöne Sendung schon vorbei. Aber wenn wir bei Leeds sind auf Rang 16, dann müssen wir auch über Everton sprechen, Everton, Everton auf Rang 17. Die haben nämlich nur drei Punkte Vorsprung auf Wattford. Die haben einen sehr bekannten Trainer, nämlich Frank Lampard. Und die haben sehr, sehr viel Unruhe im Umfeld, denn die sind so ein bisschen das umgedrehte ersten Villa. Du hast vorhin gesagt ersten Villa, die können jetzt richtig mal vielleicht oben angreifen und die bleiben ja auch schon jetzt letztlich die letzten Jahre den Top-Six immer ganz gut an den Haken kleben. Bei Everton haben wir einen turbulenten Verlauf der letzten Jahre, der eben jetzt in Abstiegskampf geführt hat, auch wenn man jetzt das letzte Spiel endlich mal wieder gewinnen konnte. Wie kritisch ist da die Situation?
Viel kritischer, als ich es zunächst angenommen habe, ehrlich gesagt. Also wenn es ein Äquivalent gibt zum HSV in Deutschland, dann ist Everton, glaube ich, sehr passend. Auch da geht los ein Nullplan hinter diesem Verein. Er ist ein Geldgeber, der will einfach an die Big Six ran, egal wie. Und er denkt, dass er das mit großen Namen schaffen kann. Da ist überhaupt keine Kontinuität auf dem Trainerposten. Inzwischen auch nicht mehr auf dem Direktor-Football-Posten. Marcel Brands entlassen worden. Dann gab es diese etwas unwürdige Geschichte mit Rafa Benitez, den, glaube ich, die Fans nicht im Ansatz gemocht haben. Sie haben ihm halbwegs verziehen, als es zu Beginn der Saison ganz gut losging. Dann sind die Ergebnisse ausgeblieben. In der Woche, in der Benitez entlassen wurden, ist der Publikumsliebling verkauft worden, Luca Dini, weil er Streit hatte mit Benitez. Am Ende der Woche wird Benitez entlassen. Lampard hat ein völlig dysfunktionales Team übernommen und hat Lampards Sachen gemacht, nämlich einfach mal freudig durchgewechselt, sowohl was das System betrifft als auch was das Personal betrifft. Das sieht man auch auf Platz, die totale Verunsicherung. Jetzt haben sie das eine nachholspiel gegen Brighton zu Zehnt gewonnen. Das war aber ein Hail Mary Angriff und nichts anderes. Das war auch Katastrophe, dieses Spiel, das hab ich gemacht. Und ja, hat ihnen jetzt Luft verschafft. Am nächsten Wochenende im FA Cup sind sie aber wieder mit vier Baden gegen Crystal Palace gegangen, die mit Verlaub ein paar Dinge richtig gut machen, aber jetzt nicht den aller ansehnlichsten Angriffsfußball spielen. Wir haben ja einfach nur zu Ende gekontert. Ich hab echt Angst um Everton. Ich fürchte oder je nachdem, wie man es sehen will, denke, dass es sich drei Schwächere finden werden, weil Everton einfach individuelle Qualität im Kader hat. Aber alles andere ist gerade nicht zu ausreichen. Die müssen sich ernsthaft Gedanken machen im Sommer, wie sie den ganzen Laden aufstellen. Und da gibt es wirklich, wirklich einiges zu tun.
Uli, jetzt ist das passiert, was ich befürchtet habe. Wir haben so schön ein Format der Ligatur eingeführt, in dem wir über alle großen europäischen Ligen –Ausnahme der Bundesliga –sprechen. Und jetzt machen wir mal wieder so eine alte Retro-Folge. Und ich lerne wieder dieses alte Format zu schätzen, weil man einfach ein bisschen mehr Zeit hat, weil wir jetzt so viele Themen abhandeln konnten und die ja trotzdem nicht am Ende sind. Wir mussten jetzt ja trotzdem Vereine weglassen, Themen weglassen und so weiter. Was ich aber sagen kann, ist, dass es wie immer ganz, ganz großen Spaß gemacht hat. Deswegen ganz herzlichen Dank, lieber Uli.
Mir hat es auch viel Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich zu hören. Ihr könnt Uli Hebel hören bei Sky. Ihr könnt ihn hören bei Click & Rush. Das wisst ihr inzwischen hoffentlich alle schon. Ansonsten solltet ihr immer eure Hörgewohnheiten hinterfragen. Und ihr könnt ihn auch bei The Zone sehen. Uli ist ein Wanderer zwischen den Welten und ein ganz hervorragender Podcast-Gast. Ich danke dir, Uli, und ich danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist weiter paywall-werbe- und sponsor-frei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwilligen Zahlungen. Unter rasenfunk.de/supportersclubkönnt ihr erfahren, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt. Und unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de gibt es jetzt auch endlich die neue Rasenfunktasse. Auch wenn ihr unser Merchandise kauft, der immer fair und möglichst lokal hergestellt ist, könnt ihr uns unterstützen. Die Tasse zum Beispiel kommt aus Deutschland, wird von Hand gefertigt und ja, vielleicht gefällt's euch ja auch. Schaut's euch an, kiosk.rasenfunk.de. Wir hören uns bald wieder hier im Rasenfunk.